streets are deserted the shops are
closed and there's an eerie sense of
foreboding
[Music]
talked to a lot of people who had go
bags with
cash and medicine and
identification papers and the gas tank
in the car was full and they were ready
to go
[Music]
the russian borders on the east so that
wasn't really an option for most folks
people have been largely fleeing west
principally to lev and and onward into
moldova or poland or elsewhere i was
lucky enough to get
lost tickets and that was a couple of
hours before the
bombing has started
i spoke to a lot of people who spent
the entire day
on the roads and still didn't make it to
the border
we know that people are taking shelter
in subways as they're really concerned
about russian bombing
i think what you're seeing in ukraine
now is is a near total disruption of
daily life
many schools are not in session many
offices are closed people are having
trouble getting money at banks a lot of
gas stations have simply run out of
gasoline
there's just simply the
fundamental uncertainty about
what russia's intentions are and
how russia could make life for average
ukrainians
more difficult as the days go by in this
conflict
of course it has the potential to
explode into a genuine refugee crisis a
genuine
economic crisis and health crisis all
wrapped up into one i mean it's going to
take time for everyone to figure out
the knock-on effects of this
you